NARRATION BY SYLVESTER
MCCOY: There once
was a clever and passionate girl
who wondered away from a fair.
She ventured inside
a wagon-like ride,
and what did she find in there?
"The Squickerwonkers."
Welcome my dears said
a voice from the winds,
to the fabulous squicker show.
You dropped in your coin,
so now you can join.
Come up here and
see how it goes.
The girl looked
around to see who
it was that spoke
with a sinister tone.
But she saw not a soul
save a rat and old.
It seemed that the
girl was alone.
And once there came
a noise from above,
nine figures swung
down from the shadows.
Their bodies hung loose
as a strung from a noose
as if all nine were
hanging from gallows.
Come on to the stage.
Don't be afraid.
Meet my motley crew.
They may have their vices
but those are my spices
and I suspect so do you.
The head of the
Squickerwonker troop
is known as Papa the Proud.
MARK DOUGLAS: All right.
That was a little bit
of "Squickerwonkers"
by Evangeline Lilly, and that
was actually her reading it,
which I was really
impressed that she
could do that with her voice.
Ladies and gentlemen,
if you could please
give a warm welcome.
You know her as "Freckles"
aka Kate from "Lost," Tauriel
from "The Hobbit," and she just
finished filming "Ant Man,"
I believe.
She's the queen of comic con.
Give it up for Evangeline Lilly.
EVANGELINE LILLY: You
have awesome hair.
Awesome hair.
I expected everyone at Google
to have awesome hair like that.
So many of you are
so much more boring
than I thought you would be.
TODD WOMACK: Come on,
give them a chance.
Give them a chance.
MARK DOUGLAS: Wow.
Way to insult the audience
right out of the gate.
EVANGELINE LILLY: All right.
But wait.
You guys are amazing.
I'm so happy to
be here at Google.
TODD WOMACK: There you go.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Google.
G-O-O-G-L-E. You know G.
TODD WOMACK: Dot com.
MARK DOUGLAS: I was trying
to get a feel for it.
I was there.
I was with you.
This is on right?
Hello?
OK.
Good.
TODD WOMACK: Who did
the voice over for that?
EVANGELINE LILLY: That was the
incredible Sylvester McCoy.
Some of you might know
him from Doctor Who.
And he was Radagast
in "The Hobbit."
He did an amazing job.
TODD WOMACK: You really
brought out the big guns.
I mean, Peter Jackson
did the forward
to this book and Fran
Walsh and Philippa Boyens
who basically write the movies.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
I was lucky enough
to be hanging out with big
guns when I made the movie,
so on their downtime, they'd
invite me over for dinner,
and I'd be like, you want
to just look at this?
I just brought something over.
It just happened
to be in my purse.
And then they were
wonderful enough
to give me their
feedback and input
and actually Fran Walsh
and Philippa Boyens
worked tirelessly with me.
They had no extra time,
but they spent ours
helping me edit the
book and make it
everything it should be.
Because I initially wrote
the story when I was 14,
and it wasn't the poem
that exists in this book.
I had to go through a ton of
rewrites to make it publishable
and make it something
they would essentially
introduce a series of 18 books.
MARK DOUGLAS: Oh, wow.
TODD WOMACK: So that
leads us to, well,
I guess we've gotten
to get a picture
from the VO and the audio what
kind of the piece is about.
MARK DOUGLAS: The general tone.
It's much scarier that way.
I was like, ooh.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
I just recently
was that the Brooklyn
Library, and I
started by asking the kids in
the audience, how many of you
have read the book,
and almost everyone
had because we had
prepped the kids.
And then basically--
MARK DOUGLAS: Did your
teacher make you read it?
EVANGELINE LILLY: And did she
tell you to say you love it?
TODD WOMACK: What
age were the kids?
EVANGELINE LILLY:
Second graders,
impossible to
control, by the way.
Second graders are crazy.
But I asked them was a scary?
Did you guys think
the book was scary?
And they were all like
no, it's not scary.
We're so tough.
And then I did it this
way with the audio
and I actually read it
instead of Sylvester.
And like I could tell that
within the second or third
page, they were all like,
I'm kind of scared now.
TODD WOMACK: They're like
this is lady is nuts.
EVANGELINE LILLY: I don't know
if it was me or the music.
MARK DOUGLAS: Mommy, why is the
pretty lady freaking us out?
EVANGELINE LILLY: Oh,
speaking of pretty lady.
It was the cutest
thing in the world.
There was this little
boy in the front row.
I mean, it was like, if you were
the little boy in the front row
and he sat there
through the whole thing.
It was so distracting and
he just kept doing this,
you are so beautiful.
I was wearing bright red
lipstick that day and you know,
little kids are suckers
for bright red lipstick.
TODD WOMACK: Are they?
MARK DOUGLAS: I think there's
a couple guys up here who
are fighting the urge
to say that right now.
You were talking about big
guns, speaking of guns,
like what do you do?
TODD WOMACK: Why did you
bring out the big guns today?
MARK DOUGLAS: Was it just
all that bow and arrow work?
EVANGELINE LILLY: No.
I mean, everyone
is always like so
what did you get a trainer
and all that stuff for roles,
and I don't do
any of that stuff.
I'm the laziest fit
person in the world.
TODD WOMACK: Do you do
like the "Rocky IV" thing?
MARK DOUGLAS: What is
the secret to that?
because I got the
lazy part down.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
The secret to that
is that for a good
10 years of my life,
I was obsessed with fitness.
So there's a lot of
muscle memory in here.
So like now like
since I had a kid,
there's just not
so much time for it
or nearly as much
passion for it.
But there was a
period in my life
where I would be the
person in the gym
for like two or three
hours at a time.
MARK DOUGLAS: In one day.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Yeah.
Sometimes twice a day.
MARK DOUGLAS: I do
that over a month.
EVANGELINE LILLY: I loved it.
I loved it for awhile.
MARK DOUGLAS: But this is
really, this is your passion.
Is this kind of an
area that you want
to go in more so
than acting even.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Well, for
anybody who is in any way,
shape or form a fan of mine,
they probably know that
I'm kind of vocal about
the fact that I'm not--
I don't love acting and it's--
MARK DOUGLAS: What?
EVANGELINE LILLY: I know.
Every struggling actress out
there just wants to lynch me.
They probably hate my guts,
but it just sort of happened,
and I got lucky, and
this thing happened,
and I was sort of taken aback
by it, and I didn't love it.
It wasn't for me
really, and so I've
continued to do it because
it's a pretty decent day job.
It pays OK.
TODD WOMACK: Not to bad.
Yeah.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
But in the meantime,
I've been working
very hard on pursuing
my actual dream and
my actual passion,
which is to be a writer.
In fact, in the last
let's see five years,
I have spent a year and
three months acting,
and I have spent the rest of
the time, full time as a writer.
MARK DOUGLAS: But it was kind of
interesting for somebody who's
not crazy about acting, you're
in some pretty cool stuff.
EVANGELINE LILLY: I know.
Isn't that great?
MARK DOUGLAS: I mean,
but it's kind of nice.
You don't have to
feel the pressure
like take every like
girlfriend part, or you know?
You get to do some
really cool stuff.
I mean like, "Ant Man,"
I mean, do you just
have nerds camping out
in your front yard?
EVANGELINE LILLY:
You know, what's
wonderful is I sort of come to
the promised land of geekdom
because I was--
MARK DOUGLAS: You're at
the very core of it now.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
I found my people.
TODD WOMACK: These people
are working on their phones
while they're listening.
That's how geeky we are.
EVANGELINE LILLY: They're
20%-ing right now.
TODD WOMACK: Oh, look at that,
throwing around the lingo.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Yeah.
I know.
I was not like the
cool girl in school.
I broke the--
TODD WOMACK: Was
that your opinion?
EVANGELINE LILLY: No.
For real.
TODD WOMACK: You
grew up in Canada.
EVANGELINE LILLY: I did.
I did.
And I will admittedly say that
because the cool girls didn't
want a pretty girl wandering
around that was outside
of their core, because
that's a threat,
I was technically allowed to
be called a part of the group,
but never, like never fit.
And I was always a loner,
and I was always on my own
because those girls would
want to get together
and I read "16 Magazine" and
go through wedding magazines
and talk crap about other
girls and probably boys,
and I just couldn't go there.
I couldn't get to it.
I was busy writing
"The Squickerwonkers."
MARK DOUGLAS: So
this wasn't just
something you pulled
out of a drawer, that
was like part of
it was made, but it
wasn't in like limerick style.
EVANGELINE LILLY: It
wasn't in limerick style,
but it was poetry.
In fact, at EvangelineLilly.com,
the original poem
is posted because it's so weird.
I was actually preparing-- I'm
doing a book tour right now
for the book.
MARK DOUGLAS: As
we speak right now.
EVANGELINE LILLY: As we speak.
Literally.
This is it.
TODD WOMACK: This is it.
Yeah.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
And I kept sort
of preparing for these
readings I was going
to do with these kids,
and it was so strange
because every time I would
prepare what would come out
of my mouth and out of my
mind was the original poem.
It gets so ingrained in my
mind, it's so much the original
that it's the one that
I keep coming back to.
So I posted it on
my website because I
thought it would
be fun for people
to see the evolution
of the story.
MARK DOUGLAS: And did
it really come out,
I mean, do you feel
confident, like does
is a really look like you
always imagined it or better?
EVANGELINE LILLY: Better.
Weirder.
Creepier.
TODD WOMACK: So yeah.
Starting there, how
about your partnership
with Johny Fraser-Allen
who illustrated the book.
He's like a Weta Workshop guy.
Right?
And that's who does all the
effects, physical and digital.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
These people are geeks.
They know who Weta Workshop is.
TODD WOMACK: Yeah.
Right.
Do you?
MARK DOUGLAS: I feel
an hour here, lady.
EVANGELINE LILLY: She's
like, I'm not that geeky, OK?
MARK DOUGLAS: "Lord
of the Rings."
They do all the "Lord
of the Rings" stuff.
TODD WOMACK: You need a
period-accurate crossbow,
call up the Weta Workshop.
So he was working there,
and you guys were obviously
spending time together
because of "The Hobbit
or what happened?
EVANGELINE LILLY: No.
It didn't quite work that way.
I was at Weta Workshop, so
Weta Workshop works similarly
to Google in the
sort of 20% notion.
They really encourage
their artists
to pursue their own passions
and their own projects,
and they sort of
facilitate that.
And I was walking around this
incredibly-creative, inspiring
building, sort of like being on
the Google campus where people
come here probably, I'm
sure you're used to this,
and they're like, oh, my god.
I would want to work
somewhere like this.
This is amazing.
And that was me.
I was that obnoxious
person at Weta.
I just being like
this is incredible.
It's this creativity factory,
and I'm a creative person,
and I've always wanted
to create my own things.
And that was one
of the tough things
about being an actor was, like
I'm not good at being the one
that someone says, do
this and then I go do it.
I'm better at saying, do this.
So I just wanted to create
something of my own,
and I've been dreaming
about and claiming
that I was going to
become a writer for about,
at that point, three years
since around the last season
of "Lost," saying this
is what I'm going to do.
I'm going to go be a writer.
But man, like just
going and being
a writer is a lot harder
than it might seem,
so I showed the head of Weta
Workshop, Richard Taylor,
some of my children's
storybooks and said
is there any illustrators
in this building who
might be interested
in partnering with me.
And Johnny fell in love
with "The Squickerwonkers"
and created this
concept painting
with these marionette puppets.
And I was like, they were not
originally marionette puppets.
Originally, all I knew was
they were human but not human,
and I knew they were a
bit creepy and weird.
But he brought the wagon,
he brought the puppets,
he brought the teddy, he
brought all this stuff
to the table that
enhanced, and just
it sort of felt
like what I didn't
know I was holding in my
brain came out of his hand.
It was incredible.
MARK DOUGLAS: So
should we tell people
a little bit about
what the story is.
It's basically a
kind of bratty girl
who comes across these
marionette characters
and they sort of teach her
a lesson-- spoiler alert--
and turn her into one of them.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Whoa.
Spoiler alert.
MARK DOUGLAS: That's
a big spoiler.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Oh, my god.
That's it.
That's the end.
No need to buy the
book now, guys.
MARK DOUGLAS: You can buy them.
It's over there at
the end, by the way.
EVANGELINE LILLY: So it's
clearly a cautionary tale,
but I'm always emphasizing
that it's intentionally
a modern-day cautionary tale.
In that the old
cautionary tales,
just programmed into kids'
minds this polarized worldview
that there's an us and a them.
There's bad guys and good guys.
And you want to be
with the good guys
so you can go kill all the bad
guys, or punish the bad guys,
or not associate with them
and exclude the bad guys.
TODD WOMACK: Let them
hang out with your group,
but not in the inner circle.
MARK DOUGLAS: Right.
Right.
EVANGELINE LILLY: I got you.
MARK DOUGLAS: I see
where this came from.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
You got my number.
I'm just getting back
at all the popular--
MARK DOUGLAS: It's
all coming together.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
--girls with this book.
Essentially what
I wanted to do was
to reprogram kids to realize
no, nobody's perfect.
Nobody's all good.
Nobody's all bad.
We've all got a bit
of vice within us,
and we've all got some
great qualities about us.
And it's all about, first
of all, accepting and loving
yourself as you are, which
the protagonist of this series
is the Squickerwonkers
who are extremely flawed,
sort of creepy,
weird-looking puppets.
So having heroes who don't
look typically like heroes,
but then also remembering
and teaching children
that there are consequences
to your actions
and so understanding
yourself and knowing yourself
on both sides, the
dark and the light,
is how you sort of can
live a happier life
and not befall the sort
of end that befalls Selma.
So I just think I
look around me and I
see a lot of entitled,
disillusioned teenagers.
Oh, yeah.
You guys know.
MARK DOUGLAS: Teenagers.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
And I think part
of that is because they were
taught in their storybooks
that if you're a good person,
life turns up perfectly,
and everything is great in your
world, and that's not real.
And they were also not told
that good people can have flaws.
There's just a lot of things
missing in the programming,
and I think that that's
one of the reasons why
if something bad happens
to them, it's like-- me?
I'm a good person.
That can't happened to me.
That's not right.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: You just go around
telling kids shit happens.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
Shit happens, dude.
Life's tough.
The sooner you wake
up to it, the better.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah.
The one part that really kind
of creeps me out about this
is, they all have
coins for our eyes.
There's something
really odd about that.
What does that have to do with--
EVANGELINE LILLY:
It's a great story.
So remember how I told
you I brought this
to a friend and Philippa and
they helped me with editing?
When I brought them the
Illustrated version,
Philippa almost peed
pants her pants,
not from excitement, from
stress because she said,
you can't do this.
You can make this book.
Everyone's going to
think it's "Coraline"
because all these puppets
had buttons for eyes.
And I'd never seen "Coraline."
I was a bit out of the loop.
And so she made me go sit
down to watch the film.
And so after the book had been
already finished illustrated,
I mean, it was done and
dusted, I watched "Coraline"
and had a conniption
because obviously, I
realized I can't repeat
what's already been done.
So we had to find
something else to put
on the eyes that wasn't buttons.
And of course, creative
projects usually
have a mind of their own,
and they find the way
to the best solution.
And what happened was I
throw this idea of maybe we
could put coins on their eyes
and then Johnny Fraser-Allen
lit up and said, you realize
that in Irish culture
you put coins on a person's
eyes at their wake.
It's like a symbol of death.
And I was thinking,
that's so good.
TODD WOMACK: Yeah.
Better than buttons.
Buttons are for
losers, "Coraline."
So what were like growing up--
EVANGELINE LILLY:
There are people
in the audience who
didn't like that.
There is like an
oh, don't go there.
TODD WOMACK: I don't care.
I'll get fired any day now.
It doesn't matter.
So growing up and maybe
after your formative years,
were there are sort of
darker influences like books
and movies that you were
into like, we were talking
about some of the
ones that we like,
like the original "Hobbit," the
animated series was a little,
especially the goblin
things, so creepy.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah,
this looks a lot
like-- has kind
of a similar style
to that cartoon, some of the
animation in the drawing.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Who wasn't
a huge fan of "Labyrinth?"
MARK DOUGLAS: Oh, yeah.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
"The Dark Crystal."
Does anyone in here--
god, it's magic.
Yeah.
Come on, with his bulging wand?
That scared me as a child.
That was the scariest
part of the movie.
Who was?
Michael Jackson?
I'm so glad it was Bowie.
MARK DOUGLAS: I
found out recently
that a lot of women of a
certain age first male crush
was David Bowie in "Labyrinth."
EVANGELINE LILLY:
In "Labyrinth".
Yes.
MARK DOUGLAS: And
that's so weird.
He's so androgynous
and kind of like-
EVANGELINE LILLY: I know.
MARK DOUGLAS: He's got
like Tina Turner hair.
My wife is like, oh my god.
EVANGELINE LILLY: But
he's an old, grown man
hitting on a child.
and all us little
11-year-olds were like, whoa.
I feel something in my pants.
I don't understand
what's happening.
MARK DOUGLAS: It's the
Bowie voice probably.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Yeah.
That helps.
And he can do that
thing with the ball.
MARK DOUGLAS: You want to go
to Chuck E. Cheese with me?
Chuck E. Cheese.
EVANGELINE LILLY: And
what about Edward Gorey.
Does anyone here
know Edward Gorey.
He was the best.
MARK DOUGLAS: So
you were definitely
into like the
creepy kid stories.
TODD WOMACK: Were
you specifically
into that kind of stuff?
EVANGELINE LILLY:
Not specifically.
It's just sort of
like across the board.
I mean, I like a
good "Giving Tree."
Everybody does.
MARK DOUGLAS: Oh, sure.
EVANGELINE LILLY: And there's
nothing creepy by "The Giving
Tree."
I like it all.
I had somebody asked me can
we do an interview with you
where you basically
tell everybody
why fluffy books suck.
And I was like, no.
I mean, I think
kids need all of it.
They need the
spectrum, and I just
see that there's a lot of sort
of kitten bubble gum books
out there.
And so we need the balance.
We need it all.
TODD WOMACK: And this is the
first of many in this series.
Yes?
EVANGELINE LILLY: Yes.
18 to be specific.
MARK DOUGLAS: Have
you written them all?
EVANGELINE LILLY: No.
I know what they'll
all-- like I know
the story for the
first nine, and then
I know the plot like the
gist for the final nine,
and the reason
for 18 as somebody
who worked on "Lost" saying
this was really important
is because I have an
overarching plan for the series.
I'm not just shooting
from the hip.
MARK DOUGLAS: Bam.
Burn.
TODD WOMACK: You
heard it here first.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
They had a plan.
I'm not knocking them, but I
know y'all didn't think they
had a plan.
TODD WOMACK: They're going
to come out of the wagon
and it's 1907.
What?
MARK DOUGLAS: I won't ask you
too many "Lost" questions,
but did you ever in
the middle of a scene
go-- what's going
on? in that show?
EVANGELINE LILLY:
All the fucking time.
All the time.
By the way, after season
three, they lost me completely.
I was like, I don't--
MARK DOUGLAS: You were like,
I'm in the corner writing
"Squickerwonkers."
And can we get her on set?
EVANGELINE LILLY:
l literally would
come to set with
alcohol because I
was like that's the
only way I'm going
to make sense of this scene.
I get a little lips--
a little loopy.
MARK DOUGLAS: Wow.
We're getting all kinds of dirt.
I mean we both love--
EVANGELINE LILLY: It's
an adult audience, right?
MARK DOUGLAS: I mean,
we both love that show.
We stuck with it
to the very end.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Thank you.
Thank you for sticking with us.
MARK DOUGLAS: My wife
was like after what
happened with Vincent,
but didn't Vincent--
he was upended at
the end, right?
Oh, no.
I said I wasn't going to
go on a "Lost" rampage.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
Your wife particularly
wants to know about Vincent.
I mean, of all the
questions she could ask me,
she wants to know what
happened to Vincent?
MARK DOUGLAS: She likes dogs.
I don't know.
OK.
Back to "The Squickerwonkers."
So when you write
a children's book,
do you consult with
child psychologists
or just kind of go for it?
Because some of our
videos on our channel
involve puppets and stuff
that kind of looks like a kid
might want to watch that,
and then the next thing
you know, the puppet
will be like doing drugs,
and we're like is this-- not
that any of the Squickerwonkers
do drugs.
EVANGELINE LILLY: One
of them does smoke,
and I got a lot
of flack for that.
MARK DOUGLAS: So do you
worry about that stuff?
EVANGELINE LILLY: You know,
if I worried about it,
this would not exist.
I'm tell you, everybody told
me, everybody told me no.
Nobody would publish this book.
People were like,
we're not going
near that with a 10-foot pole.
I had a really big publisher
outright tell me not like,
in my opinion, or for this
particular publishing company,
it was outright, you
will not be successful.
That book won't sell.
And I just thought, I
think I'm on to something.
This has got to
be good if people
have such an extreme
reaction to it.
So no, I didn't consult
any child psychologists.
TODD WOMACK: That was
his question, by the way.
MARK DOUGLAS: No,
I'm just curious.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
But I did explore
a lot of the psychology
of childhood,
and I call it a
playground drama because I
think we forget that the
scariest people on earth
are children.
"Lord of the Flies" might be
the scariest story in the world
because kids are crazy.
They don't have any
sense of right and wrong.
sense of boundaries,
and they just like
attack each other
on the playground for
absolutely no reason.
But adults are never
talking to kids
about all that
craziness and darkness
that they deal
with day in and day
out with each other in their
social circles, and their lost.
They're left to sort of navigate
those waters on their own.
And so I did think a ton
about child psychology
when I was writing the book.
TODD WOMACK: And when
you go into this place
where you're writing these
books-- I know you have a child
and you have a lot of
projects and so forth.
Where do you go, like
physically and emotionally
to like work on these?
EVANGELINE LILLY:
Because I am a mom,
I don't go where I would
probably otherwise, go
and I think otherwise I
would like go on a trip,
or I would go to some beautiful
location day in and day out
and be doing it there.
Instead, I work from home.
I have a home office.
It's beautiful.
I mean, it overlooks a jungle,
and it's very inspiring,
and it's lovely.
But my son regularly
through the day
comes pitter-pattering
up the stairs
and comes mommy do you
want to play with me,
and we talk and we have a moment
and then he goes away again.
And the nice thing is that
he has this really delusional
concept that everybody has two
parents at home all the time.
Because he has a
stay-at-home dad, and he's
very, very fortunate
in that way.
So that's one of the ways
that I kind of am juggling it
all is that I work from home
so that I'm also very present
for my son even though I'm
working ridiculously hard.
TODD WOMACK: You're writing
a demented children's book
in the other room.
EVANGELINE LILLY: By
the way, he loves it.
He's three and a
half, and he loves it.
MARK DOUGLAS: That's great.
I really think it's a fun book.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
Like, when she gets--
as soon as she turns into
the puppet at the end
and then the curtain closes in a
sort of morbid way of like they
end it with like the curtain
closes, and you're like, what?
That's it?
She's gone.
There's like a rat
dusting the stage.
And my son, it's
his favorite page.
It's nothing but a
rat dusting the page,
but it's like she got locked.
Yeah.
Because he gets
locked in his room
all the time for
throwing tantrums.
TODD WOMACK: All right.
Is there a little piece you in
any of the characters, maybe
the main character?
EVANGELINE LILLY:
Everyone asked that.
Everyone always asks me that.
TODD WOMACK: No,
when you were young.
EVANGELINE LILLY: It's fair.
It's a fair question.
Everything I write now by the
way, everything I write now,
I am the protagonist.
I am fully self-involved
in that way,
but this one I wrote before the
self-involvement settled in.
I was too young, and
it isn't really me,
but my favorite character
is Greer the Greedy
because she's bonkers.
I mean, she's just nuts,
and I love nuts people.
In fact, that was a note
that I got for my publisher.
In the book, it actually
says that she's crazy,
and they were like,
you can't say that.
You can't say that.
That's politically
incorrect because you
don't talk about crazy
people because there
are actual crazy
people out there.
I was like, I know.
I have so many in my family.
That's why I want
to talk about them.
MARK DOUGLAS: If you
were a Squickerwonker,
what would you name be.
There's a lot of alliteration,
Papa the Proud, Mama the Mean.
EVANGELINE LILLY: If I
was a Squickerwonker,
I would be Sally
the Self-involved.
MARK DOUGLAS: Todd,
what about you?
TODD WOMACK: Todd the Turtle.
I don't know.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Turtle?
TODD WOMACK: Slow.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
That's not a vice.
TODD WOMACK: Slow and lazy,
and I like lettuce a lot.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah.
I think maybe like
Mark the Motionless.
We both have a similar problem.
EVANGELINE LILLY: They're
emphasizing their laziness.
TODD WOMACK: On that note,
we do have a couple of mics
out here, guys, and if you
want to ask a question,
feel free to approach
one of those mics
and we'll call on you
when it's your turn.
In the audio book, I noticed
does it ever go full-on song?
EVANGELINE LILLY:
Not full-on song.
There are moments where
the Squickerwonkers start
humming out of tune because
they can't sing very well.
But no, I mean, there
is an audio book
that will be exclusively
for sale on audible.com,
well not exclusively on
audible, because they've put it
on all different platforms
like iTunes and Amazon.
But there will be
an interactive book
exclusively for
sale on iTunes where
there will be little
interactive elements for kids
like you can change the sepia
images in the book to color
or maybe little
bits of animation.
There's a little
pop-up video by me
and the Illustrator at the end
where I kind of help parents
figure out how to talk to their
kids about this crazy book
because I think they'll be
a bit at a loss at the end
when their child says, what?
And they go, I don't know.
Let's not read it again.
So there's a video there to
help sort of guide parents
through that conversation.
By the way, speaking of
having to read it over
and over and over, again
that was one of our goals.
Johnny and I when we set
out to make this book,
we were like, OK, how many
parents dread reading time
with their kids because
they're like I'm
going to have to read where
is spot for the 700th time,
and I'm over it.
So we were like, we've got
to make a book that even
parents would be like, let's
read "The Squickerwonkers"
again, you know?
So it was like appealing to
hopefully all generations,
like all demographics,
parents, teenagers.
My 14-year-old
niece, when I first
read it to her, not because
it's really her demographic just
because I love my
niece and we're close.
I read it to her and she
was like, oh, it's so good.
It's really good.
And then she got really
embarrassed and upset
for a moment out of nowhere,
and she goes, wait a minute.
Auntie, is this a
book for little kids?
And I was like,
well, technically.
But I think it's for
everybody, like for anybody.
I like it.
I'm an adult, and I like it.
She was like, I was so
embarrassed for a minute
because I really like
it, and I really want it.
I was like awesome.
That was great.
TODD WOMACK: It's $14.95.
MARK DOUGLAS: I think it's
nice that you give kids
credit to sort of grasp some
of these concepts of like,
the main character,
she's not all bad,
and the Squickerwonkers
aren't all bad,
and they're not all good.
I mean, I know my mom let
me read Stephen King when
I was a kid just because she
was happy that I was reading
anything, and I'm pretty
disturbed because of it,
but I do read.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Hey, you got
four million followers, man.
Disturbed works for you.
TODD WOMACK: So
is there any plan?
I see the audio is great and
the visuals are really awesome.
Is there any plan to make
an animated thing out of it?
EVANGELINE LILLY: Do any
of you know who LAIKA is?
Do you know the company LAIKA?
You know the
company LAIKA, yeah,
like they made "Coraline"
and "ParaNorman"
and the amazing "Boxtrolls."
Have you guys seen
"Boxtrolls" yet?
It is so good, so, so good.
I've had conversations
with them about it,
and I'm not ready
to make a movie yet
and they're not really ready
to make a dark movie right
now because they just
made three in a row.
MARK DOUGLAS: You
could get Peter Jackson
to make a three-hour
version of this one book.
EVANGELINE LILLY: A
three three-hour version.
MARK DOUGLAS: No, sorry.
Go ahead.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Hey,
man, I'm with you.
I was a huge "Hobbit" fan, OK?
And it was supposed to
be two movies originally,
and then when they turned it
into three, I was like oh, no.
no, you didn't.
MARK DOUGLAS: They shot
those like did 1984.
I know it was a long time ago.
EVANGELINE LILLY: I know.
I know.
People were like, oh, are
you sad that it's over?
I was like, well, I was six
years ago when it ended.
MARK DOUGLAS: I'm like, I
didn't even want to be in it.
Did you have to
audition for that?
I feel like he
kind of hand picks,
he has like visions of people.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
This is not a lie.
This is the truth.
He told me in 2004 he
wanted me to play an elf.
He was like, if I had been
casting "Lord of the Rings"
before you like
became an actress,
I would have made you an elf.
MARK DOUGLAS: Like if he saw
you on the street he'd be like,
you're an elf.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Seriously,
but at the moment,
it was the most crushing thing
he could have ever said to me.
I mean, I felt like I could
have dropped to my knees
and bawled my eyes
out because I was
like I would have
died to be an elf.
I wanted to be an
elf all my life.
And then you just gave it to
me and took it right away.
But then like 10
years later, he was
like hey you want to be an elf?
MARK DOUGLAS: So he
just added an elf.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Yeah, he did.
He was like I'm just going
to put an elf in this movie.
MARK DOUGLAS: And elves are
the best looking in that world,
right?
TODD WOMACK: By far.
By far.
EVANGELINE LILLY: I don't know.
I don't know.
Humans like Aragorn?
Come on.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah,
you've got to go Viggo.
Where's the king?
He's got to be the most
handsome guy in the whole world.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
He's pretty hot.
TODD WOMACK: Does anybody
else have a question?
Any questions?
Go ahead to the microphone so
we can get it on film here.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Don't be shy.
You with the
humongous earphones.
TODD WOMACK: Start over here.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Those are
in case I was too obnoxious
and he needed to
like muffle his ears
and not have to listen to this.
AUDIENCE: Actually
those are so I
could make good use
of my walking up here.
In terms of other
demented children's books,
can you recommend some more?
I'm thinking "Belloc's
Cautionary Tales"
and things like that as well.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
Yeah, well, I mean,
I actually can say that
when I was a little girl,
I was quite literarily deprived
because my parents were blue
collar, small-town
Canadian people.
They did not have
university educations.
I don't even remember ever
being read to us a child.
TODD WOMACK: Not even on
the back of a Labatts bottle
or something like that?
EVANGELINE LILLY: Yeah,
something like that.
TODD WOMACK: Canada jokes.
MARK DOUGLAS: Like watch
the hockey game, eh?
EVANGELINE LILLY: Yeah.
Exactly.
But thankfully my grandfather
gave me some good dark books.
So I don't have like a massive
library of them in my mind,
but I mean, more recently, since
I started writing this book,
I've become more aware
of who's out there now.
They weren't so much
as a kid or at least
I wasn't aware of them.
But like Gris Grimly,
he's incredible
and his art is amazing.
He has this weird way of
making creepy art look cute.
It's great because
it like tricks kids
into thinking it's a
cute story and then
they're always kind
of horrific and scary.
And then there's like
Neil Gaiman, of course.
He's like the king of dark,
and I mean, even as an adult,
his stories scare
the crap out of me.
They're very, I
mean, then he goes
to the whole other extreme.
And he's always said like
stories are meant for escapism
so don't limit where
people escape to.
If they want to
go somewhere dark,
let them go somewhere dark.
MARK DOUGLAS: How about
a question over here?
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for being here.
I'm a huge, huge fan.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And I
don't have any kids,
but I still bought two
books for my future kids.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Don't
have two so-- I have
a "Lost" question
if you don't mind.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
You know, it's funny
when they said, does
anyone have any questions,
you can go to the mic and
nobody went to the mic.
I was going to be like, guys,
you can ask me about "Lost."
MARK DOUGLAS: I was about
to say the same thing.
AUDIENCE: I stuck it to the end.
It really opened me up
as a person, I think.
And I have a question
about Jack and Sawyer.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
Of course, you do.
MARK DOUGLAS: We
were going to call
you Freckles the whole time.
EVANGELINE LILLY: I'm
not going to tell you
who's a better kisser if
that's what you're asking.
AUDIENCE: Something more
metaphysical than that.
EVANGELINE LILLY: More
physical than that?
MARK DOUGLAS: Metaphysical.
AUDIENCE: Metaphysical.
So suppose you were not tied
to your character in the story,
but you were you
as in real life.
Who would you have a crush
on in terms of the character?
MARK DOUGLAS: Do you know
what metaphysical means?
You work at Google, man.
EVANGELINE LILLY: What
he means is, which chakra
would respond to
which of those men?
MARK DOUGLAS: Jack or Sawyer.
Easy question.
Come on.
EVANGELINE LILLY: It's
not an easy question.
OK, let's see.
I mean, I like rugged men.
I like men who typically
are kind of like manly men.
No offense to all
the metrosexual men
in the audience.
You're awesome too.
And I've dated my fair
share of metrosexuals,
but they're both manly.
It's just like the whole stupid
good guy, bad guy argument,
and of course, everybody
knows the girls
typically like the bad
guy when they're young
and then they get their hearts
stomped on enough times,
and they go maybe I'll
settle for a good guy.
And then they stick with the
good guys, and like oh, no.
I just want a good guy.
That's all it is.
I just really wanted a
good guy when really they
just settled for them.
And then when the bad guys
come around, they're like,
oh, I'm kind of tempted.
No, I'll stay with my good guy.
I'm kind of tempted.
And that's my way of
skirting around the question
and not answering it.
MARK DOUGLAS: That's pretty
metaphysical though, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Then you
would want Sawyer then.
I take it that is the answer.
Right?
EVANGELINE LILLY:
That is the point
of "Lost" is you're going to
interpret my answer however
you want to interpret it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MARK DOUGLAS: You've got a
metaphysical answer for sure.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Thank you.
TODD WOMACK: How
about over here.
AUDIENCE: So I have
a kid on the way,
so I'm looking for
children's books, so thanks.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Awesome.
AUDIENCE: My question was, it
was originally a poem that you
wrote when you were young
and then obviously, you
made an important stylistical
change by turning it
into limericks, but it's
still the original version
that sticks in your mind.
So are you happy with the fact
that you transformed the style
and why do you feel that this is
a better way to tell the story?
EVANGELINE LILLY: That was
a really good question.
Thank you.
I don't know, actually.
I ask myself that all
the time, like why
did I go away from
the original story
because sometimes I miss
it, like sometimes I
like the simplicity
and sweetness of it.
But there were some very
worthwhile reasons why I did.
One of them was, my editor was
like, you have to fix this.
It's not very good.
It's got something in there,
but it's just not that good yet.
And then the other one
was, over the 20 years
that I had it in my
mind, it had sort of
brewed into a series of stories.
It brewed into more
than it originally
was where I started
to think about, well,
who are the other
"Squickerwonker" characters
and when I say "The
Squickerwonkers,"
there's only one person who
originally was narrating it,
which was Papa the Proud and
so who are the other ones.
And his name wasn't Papa
the Proud at that time.
And so then it was
like, well, if I'm
going to expand it out
into a series which
is what I feel it
wants to be, then I
have to change the story so that
it sets up a world that sets up
the characters so that you could
be introduced and ushered in,
and then the series would
carry on and open up the world.
The original was just
a very standalone poem.
It was just silly and
the simple and this one
has a lot more depth.
Thank you.
MARK DOUGLAS: And
I think we're going
to do two more questions so we
have time for the book signing.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
You're great laugher.
I saw you in the
crowd, and I was
like, I'm just going
to focus on that guy.
He's a great laugher.
AUDIENCE: Years of practice.
EVANGELINE LILLY: That's great.
You're probably the healthiest
person on the planet.
AUDIENCE: So I know you have
this grand vision for 18
books that building
on this one, but I
was wondering if you would
see yourself ever writing
adult books or like young
adult fiction instead of just--
EVANGELINE LILLY:
He did say fuction.
You didn't hear it wrong.
He said fuction.
We're going metaphysical
again, guys.
MARK DOUGLAS: Maybe
he's from New Zealand.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Fuction.
MARK DOUGLAS: Love fuction.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Me too.
Love my fuction.
So 2015, the plan is Titan have
partnered with me to publish
a graphic novel series,
which will be geared
towards young adults and adults.
And it's based on a screenplay
that I wrote about six
or seven years ago
called "The Fortress."
And my plan is to also
take time during that year
while we're building
up the graphic novel
series to write a novel
series based on this story.
So I'm excited to
dive into novel work
because one of the things
that is so hard about writing
for children is you have to
have so much self-restraint
because the amount of
words you're allowed
to have in the book is so few
that to get across everything
you want to tell is a very,
very difficult in such a
tiny amount of time.
So I'm really excited to just
sort of take off the chains
and write my heart
out and create novels.
Let's see if I can do it.
I actually have no
idea if I can do it.
MARK DOUGLAS: You can't do it.
That was a great question.
How about the next one.
AUDIENCE: My name is Becky.
Hey, what's up?
EVANGELINE LILLY:
AUDIENCE: Hey, that's my girl.
I don't have a question.
I've been stalking
you for years.
I know everything about you.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
Awesome. [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I had an
invitation, actually.
I and a lot of people at
Google work in a program
called Citizen Schools.
It's really amazing, and we work
with a group of kids in Harlem.
They're sixth graders.
It's a struggling school.
Really awesome kids, and
we go there every week.
And I was trying to
look up your book tour,
and I couldn't really
find the dates,
so you might want to talk to
people about like getting that
up.
EVANGELINE LILLY: What?
It's on my website.
It's on all my socials.
It's all over my--
AUDIENCE: Very well on mobile
perhaps, but my problem.
But I'm not sure
if you're around--
EVANGELINE LILLY:
Definitely my problem.
AUDIENCE: --in New York
City on December 8,
but the kids are
coming to Google
for their final presentations.
They do this big thing called
the WOW where they teach back
and they get really excited.
So if you are in town, I do
want to invite you to this.
This is school's WOW on
Google on December 8.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Thank you,
thank you, thank you, thank you
for the invitation.
I will be on a "Hobbit"
press tour at that time.
AUDIENCE: Eh, that's fine.
EVANGELINE LILLY: I'm sorry.
MARK DOUGLAS: Maybe
next time though.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
for coming here.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Yeah.
Book number two is
coming out next year,
and I will make sure, I will
mention that to my peeps
so that we can put it
in the tour next year.
I would love to do that.
That sounds amazing.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Right on.
EVANGELINE LILLY: And you're
also a great audience member.
I heard all your like
comments and laughing.
Love it.
Chee-hoo.
MARK DOUGLAS: I'll ask you
one more thing before we go.
EVANGELINE LILLY: You
said two more questions.
Maybe you're Greer the Greedy.
MARK DOUGLAS: All right.
EVANGELINE LILLY: No, ask me.
Ask me.
I don't want this to end.
MARK DOUGLAS: Once my mom caught
me lying when I was a kid,
and she read "Pinocchio" to me.
And when would you suggest
reading this to a child?
EVANGELINE LILLY: I would
suggest reading this
to your child when they have
a super duper big tantrum
for absolutely no good
reason to have a big tantrum.
It's a great teachable
book in that way.
Like in the end, the kid
gets totally punished
for their tantrum,
and there's no out.
There's no like,
oh, but it was OK.
That's a rule in my house.
If my son is misbehaving--
MARK DOUGLAS: Buttons
go in the eyes.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Yeah.
Boom.
No, the coin.
The coins.
MARK DOUGLAS: I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Coins.
EVANGELINE LILLY: But like if
he has to apologize to somebody
and they go, it's OK.
I go no, it's not OK.
It's not OK.
You can say thank
you for your apology,
or I forgive you, or let's move
on from this, but it's not OK.
And I just think too many times
kids are like told, but it's OK
and it's no.
You were misbehaving.
Locked.
TODD WOMACK: Lock him up.
You heard it here.
MARK DOUGLAS: Ladies and
gentlemen, I think that's it.
I think we're going to--
AUDIENCE: How about
a little round
of applause for a
special guest today.
Thank you very much
for joining us.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah.
Thank you much for coming.
TODD WOMACK: And we'll let
you get over to the thing
and do some signing.